let's talk about gay stuff because it
was a pretty good week already for the
gays and it's only Wednesday yesterday a
federal judge ruled that Oklahoma's gay
marriage ban was unconstitutional let's
take a look at a quote equal protection
is at the very heart of our legal system
and central to our consent to be
governed it is not a scarce commodity to
be meted out but grudgingly or in short
portions therefore the majority view in
Oklahoma must give way to individual
constitutional rights now he immediately
stayed the decision so gays can't get
married immediately in Oklahoma and
already you know couple ago this
happened in Utah they had it temporarily
now it looks like it's gonna go to the
Supreme Court uh so I'm gonna pretty
much think we all agree that this is
basically good right gays equality are
we okay with quality super against
completely against the game what is it
no okay so all right so we're agreed on
the equality thing so I'm going to
switch gears a little bit do is there a
risk in this all happening by judges are
we just strengthening the resolve of the
other side is the Tea Party are those
people just going to be more pissed
because they're going to say it's not
the will of the people it's the activist
judges that are giving the gays all this
power is being like no I mean I don't
think if you were a tea party guy and
you were against these judges making
decisions that you wouldn't this
wouldn't strengthen your dash I mean
yeah I guess potentially potentially I
just can't wait until we get to a point
where we don't have to celebrate common
sense you know I trust me I did not want
to do that I can't wait till we don't
have to do about these stories like I I
don't think that will be and I mean I
think people will complain because
people complain yeah and so if you're
losing your gonna be like this is not
the way it should be done right let's do
it away where we win I think I'll be
okay with it being done the other
exactly because we've seen we've seen
cases where the people have voted in
favor of gay marriage and then people
are upset for other you know there's
always bitter losers yeah but I think
I've won equality in this country
usually goes one way it doesn't it's
very rare that rights are taken away
from people continuously or for a long
time when they are it's usually quickly
reversed and out rate you know and we're
seeing that now with that with this
issue you know when utah has judges
being like you get like they're gay
married people in utah like there's
gonna be gay marriage in utah right it
may not happen again tomorrow but that's
gonna happen now and it doesn't go it's
not gonna go back right so the people in
utah for example that are fighting it i
mean they don't they know that they're
fighting a losing cause here because
it's exactly what happened in California
there was the temporary okay and now
couple thousand people and in utah r
married and they know that they're not
going to get it back so is it just that
they just can't give up their what they
view as the the righteous fight or
whatever you think it's just they can't
give up that religious fervor that
religious yeah craziness it is craziness
um yeah i don't know i mean i just i
hope that they get it back you know i
think they can't give up the fight
because it is this thing they can go to
church and feel like they're being
wholly or something i don't i don't know
I was raised Catholic and one of the
cool like the fact that I've for the
first time ever I'm like hey miss Pope's
not bad like that's like even that's
moving in a good direction so I I do
think i think in terms of judges to like
equality and those countries always
dealt like doled out by activist judges
like well you know Brown versus Board
magically it's all you know roe v wade
like these are all you know decisions
I've stood for a long time that doesn't
mean people won't try to overturn them
as we see with roe v wade constantly but
you know it's that's that's how this
works that's their job to is to be like
hey you guys aren't protecting everybody
like will protect me write anything that
also the irony of the people that they
say they're so for the Constitution but
we have separation of powers and if they
believe in the Constitution well then
they should believe that if a judge says
this is unconstitutional even if they
don't like it they should abide by it
but somehow they don't always why can't
they also be on the side of the people
when it comes to net neutrality makes
you wonder yeah makes you wonder you
know so governor mary Fallin who's the
governor of Oklahoma she said that the
people of Oklahoma have spoken on the
issue noting that seventy five percent
of the voters supported traditional
definition of marriage
but I bet sixty years ago they supported
to white people and to black people
getting me we support the two black
people getting there but as long as they
weren't marrying white people it was
better yeah it's you this is an issue
where I don't trust the will of the
people like the fact is there's a right
there is a wrong and it is the
government's job to make sure that all
people are treated equally and so if you
have bigoted people in an area we're
gonna vote for something and bigoted is
maybe a strong word they're people
different you know blah blah but it is a
bigoted stance right at this point at
this point well because that's the other
thing and this will be the final thought
on this that uh for these people that
are against it it every time there is
gay marriage somewhere it does none of
the things they say are proven true it
doesn't cause straight people to get
divorced or ruin families it actually
strengthens families they've even done
research that straight marriages even
strengthened in bizarre ways because you
have healthier families and people in a
yeah yeah